Gilbert has a special lady in his life
you don't know that who's it and she's
Asian Jessica no I think Jessica's for
who is it I'm not just a just girl I'm
talking to you right now do I know her
no no give you a vote in the beginning
phase very beginning phase no we're not
gonna ruin it for him like Kentucky for
a bit I do want to say this no no no
you're not gonna switch the topics
you're not gonna sway no I'm telling you
but tell me why he cares no no not that
this is more important memory you guys
told me and like episode yeah something
early on data asian girl yeah trying it
yes let me tell you something yeah
you're something different about it I
love it the cultural understanding of
things yeah and I love the way you
shifted the tempo of the direction of
your thing so that I don't see a photo
no photo no photo on social media
there's not a single photo online of
this now I'm sure there's something on a
Facebook with no photos we're also not
gonna we're not gonna we're gonna make
I'll show you later I see oh you know
you
I can't shutting this off okay that's
fine okay
thanks tiger belly I'm not kidding I'm
not kidding either now you're sitting
back down okay okay it's good it's done
can you calm down he cares about this
girl and can you not ruin it for
somebody and here's my evidence cuz I
will not let this girl that I'm talking
to be body shamed by a celebrity body
shame wins by Sarah no just I don't like
it bad what if she is is that a problem
no yes it is
no that's why I'm not showing you photos
she's not fat she's very pretty
forty pounds too chunky the only one who
let me say this oh my problem with him
doing this moment you say this yeah I
wanted treat you guys it's good to sound
we're like my parents so where's this I
really don't think my mom has always
told me that she's like never ever bring
a girl home I don't care if you're
dating here whatever
unless she is the one yeah then you can
introduce me here all the other girls
just white noise give me a couple get a
couple months and find out
yeah don't introduce you to pop by mama
thank you thank you okay that's fine
and also if you all you would ever need
to say to me is look she's special I
care about this girl and I would show
you the most but most respect yeah maybe
I do take a couple digs at other girls
that you've been with because they're
throwaways and I know you don't agree
that specially and they're not
impressive so obviously I'm gonna give
you my most honest opinion
but even if suppose I'm not fully
impressed by this girl but if you loved
her and you cared about her I would
never show I would only show respect to
you and her I would never [ __ ] and
say anything bad about her in this
podcast he would on the other hand
anytime his brother comes to him says
Bob I met this girl show me a picture
show me a picture no and then he you
know he there's this 30 minute whole
thing show me a [ __ ] picture same
thing that's going on right now finally
Steve shows him a picture first thing he
says it's yeah yuck you get inside that
Wow he's awful he's awful so I
understand where you're coming from and
never show him a picture why don't you
do some that times right yeah come on
baby be nice just be happy for him it's
an Asian man this is it this is a big
step okay is she in comedy no she's not
an actress she's civilian the
entertainment industry she's an agent
no she's not right I'll just say this
producer that's it Oh fancy
I know very ambitious all right fine I I
don't care anymore okay
yeah I don't care anymore what else do
you guys want to talk about today what
do you mean why why was that I'm trying
to switch the subject why was I can feel
Gilbert you know feeling uh serious
about this
[Music]